لكن رغم تلك اللحظه المثيره للجدال ظل
رونالدو يقدم اداء عالميا المستوى ظل يسجل
الاهداف بين اسبوع واخر وحضوره يجذب حدود
المعجبين في اي مكان يقصده في تشرين
الثاني عام 2019 سجل رونالدو ثلاثيه اخرى
للبرتغال في التصفيات المؤهله لبطوله امم
اوروبا 2020 تضاف الى انجازاته مع منتخب
بلاده يريد الكره وكذلك رونالدو وقد سجل
الثلاثيه
[تصفيق]
كانت كره حتميه
يتصدر النجم عناوين الاخبار مجددا
يجدر القول ان رونالدو هو اللاعب الاكثر
شعبيه في هذه الرياضه ويحظى بسهوله باضخم
قاعده معجبين بين جميع اللاعبين في العالم
لكنه ليس لعب كره قدم محبوبا فحسب بل هو
ايضا رجل اعمال ذكي منذ ان كان في مانشستر
يونايتد انخرط رونالدو في صفقات تجاريه
عده في اشاره الى شركته الاسطوريه سي ار 7
فقد اطلق عطورا وظهر على واجهه العاب
الفيديو المرتبطه بكره القدم ويمتلك خطه
التجاريه لصناعه الالبسه الداخليه كذلك
لديه علاماته التجاريه في مجال الملابس
ما هي رائحه كريستيانو رونالدو حسن في
الحقيقه احب دائما ان تكون الرائحه جميله
وهذه تجربه الثالثه هذا العطر رائحته
ناعمه وخفيفه
ويمكنك ان تتخيلي كم انا سعيد فالرائحه
فواحه لا اعرف اذا شممت رائحه العطر اذا
انه نعم انا احبه كثيرا واصبح اكثر من
لاعب كره قدم خلال عقدين من الزمن صار
تقريبا علامه تجاريه بتلك الوقفه الشهيره
قبل تنفيذه ركله حره على اعلانات عطور سي
ار 7 والمتحف في جزيرته في ماديرا وكل ما
يحيط برونالدو وقد اعتنق ذلك فهو رجل
استعراضي ورجل اعمال محنك وهو يفهم حتما
اهميه موقعه ضمن نجوميه العالم
ما الهدف من الاستثمار في هذا
المشروب حسن في الحقيقه انها فرصه كبيره
وجميله فالمجال الصحي يعنيني كثيرا علينا
بذل كل الامكانات والجهود للاستثمار في
هذا المجال
وشريكي ايضا يساعدني ويعجبه هذا المشروع
وهو شخص لديه رؤيه عالميه وانا سعيد جدا
بشراكه معه انه مميز وعلاوه على ذلك يقدم
الكثير من الدعم للمجتمعات الفقيره منذ
عام 2014 عمل رونالدو بالتعاون مع منظمه
سيف ذا تشيلدرين لمساعده الاطفال الذين
عانوا من الحروب او اصيبوا بامراض خطيره
في ارجاء العالم كذلك صار سفيرا للمنظمه
وواصل اجراء الحملات لهم في شكل منتظم
[موسيقى]
كما يتبرع رونالدو بمكافاته الكرويه
للجمعيات الخيريه التي يختارها عام 2013
تمت تسميه رونالدو في صفوف فريق العام
للاتحاد الاوروبي لكره القدم وحقق له ذلك
89 الف جنيه تم تقديم هذا المال مباشره
الى جمعيه الصليب الاحمر الخيريه كذلك نال
مكافاه قدرها 450,000 جنيه تبرع بها لسيف
ذا تشيلدرين واليونيسف وورد فيجن ثلاثه
منظمات خيريه هو سفيرها
[موسيقى]
ممنوع ان يجروا خلفك اذا تجاوزتها هؤلاء
الاطفال العشرين حسنا جرب حظك هيا بنا هيا
[موسيقى]
حسن انها فرصه لدعم الطبيعه حدث هذا عندما
ولدت في موطني وهذا الموقف معقد بالنسبه
الى الناس الذين يعيشون هناك الشيء الوحيد
الذي يمكنني قوله عليهم الاستمرار في
العمل والنضال لتتحسن الاوضاع والا يفقد
الامل اعرف انه موقف معقد بالنسبه الى
العائلات والاشخاص والاولاد ولكن الكلمه
الوحيده الان هي التحلي بالصبر
[موسيقى]
تصعب معرفه متى سيتوقف رونالدو في النهايه
سيتوقف حتما في مرحله ما كما يقول هو
بنفسه يعتقد ان امامه اربعه او خمسه او
سته مواسم لانه حافظ على لياقه بدنيه
عاليه وممتازه فجسده جسد شاب اصغر سنا وقد
يكون محقا في ذلك لا اراه ينهي رحلته في
نادي صغير في البرتغال اتخيل له توقفا
مفاجئا وحينها سيدرك العالم انه فقد
بالتاكيد واحدا من افضل ثلاثه او اربعه
لاعبين على الاطلاق
سيتم تذكره دوما بانه احد اعظم لاعب كره
القدم على مر العصور وحتى حين يعتزل اللعب
سيميز محب كره القدم علامته التجاريه سي
ار 7 وسيعرفون دائما اسماء كريستيانو
رونالدو
اعتقد ان رونالدو وعلينا ذكر ميسي قد غير
طريقه دعم ناشئه لكره القدم في صغر ربما
كنا ندعم فريقنا المحلي ثم مؤخرا ربما
تشجع اكبر الفرق في بلدك خلال طفولتك
والان اعتقد ان الاطفال في انحاء العالم
في سن العاشره يقولون انهم يشجعون ريال
مدريد بسبب رونالدو او يشجعون برشلونه
بسبب ميسي لقد قسم الاطفال الى طوابير
المشجعين في العالم اما ان تكون في صف
رونالدو او ميسي واما انك مع ريال مدريد
او برشلونه ولا يهم ان كنت في مانشستر
او مدريد او مالمو اما انك مع ريال مدريد
واما مع برشلونه بسبب رونالدو او ميسي
انا سعيد للغايه بوجود هنا مع هؤلاء
اللاعبين وهذا المدرب لانها فرصه رائعه لي
ساتعلم شيئا جديدا دوما واريد مواصله
مسيرتي هكذا سنه تلو الاخرى
[موسيقى]